how are you
it's so good to see you even virtually
hello good to see you been a while uh
yes it has been at least a week or two
maybe maybe three hey time is elastic
so who knows what's happening yeah
believe me i would love to [ __ ] with
you for four minutes and and catch up
but i have to go
let's get into it yeah i was gonna be
like so uh first let me say like
uh the first three episodes are awesome
and marvel's swinging big with this and
i love it
um when you first got involved uh
how much did they tell you about like
the character and the ultimate arc of
where all this is gonna go
and if you might be in the mcu in the
future and how much is it sort of like
marvel's interested
yeah just sign me up um they told me the
arc of the show
of the of the limited series um and so i
i
i knew where this particular show where
where this
where this show goes and they had to
tell
they had to kind of walk it through
through me twice
but they did but they did um that i know
what's happening
um with this show and i knew i
was like i if you guys can pull this off
it's so ambitious and so exciting and
i uh i was just so thrilled and i
i can't it's yeah
what's interesting is that like you're
you're doing one of these projects where
you have to talk about it but yet you
can't say anything
yeah i mean i can say i can say enough i
can say a bunch steve
you know i can say i mean i love i can't
i can say that i can't believe that my
entrance
into this world is into a 56 black and
white sitcom
that's something i didn't see coming in
the course of my career which is kind of
a real a real awesome surprise and very
surreal
okay uh what was it what was it like
because of your first time working with
marvel
what maybe surprised you about making
the series that you didn't expect going
in
um i guess i just had a i guess what
what surprised me
was the um the artisans that work
on the on these shows like the i mean on
this show at least but i guess in these
movies like
there's so much crossover all the time
like the the production
design the air the makeup the the
the i mean i was blown away
by the artist the costume designer mayas
like
blown away by the detail and the and the
artisans that work on these from
um from all angles i was also really
like
moved and excited and surprised by the
feeling of family that i
that i felt but anyway it was really
sweet
uh i want to touch on two other things
because i'm about to run out of time
with you
uh are you doing spider verse two
not that i've heard but i would love to
but not
i've heard got it i do hope i do hope
you get to be in it because you know the
first one is
amazing it's amazing amazing um i'm so
proud of that thing
uh i was a huge fan of season one of
central park
um and so i have to ask you what's it
been like working on season two
because one of the things i love about
the first season are the songs and
like the family dynamic it's just so
well done so what what can you tease
about the second season
i mean i can say that i've been we've
all been dutifully recording
in our various homes like i've set up my
garage as a
as a recording studio i have like moving
blankets
like taped to the walls and so we're all
we're all plugging through and i think
that the songwriters um
and artists that they got on are are
like really exciting i can't disclose
any of them but you're gonna be so
excited like
there's some really incredible
songwriters for this next season
uh i already have to stop i'm just gonna
say congrats i really can't wait to see
where this goes and
we'll talk more once i've seen more
please all right
it's a date